so I think that I think the first
question I wanted to ask you is like
given the popularity of AI or at least
the interest in AI right now what was it
like when you're doing your PhD thesis
in the 80s around AI yeah well very
different
I mean it's is quite a surprise for me
to find myself in this current position
where everybody and everyone is
interested in what I'm doing a media are
interested you know corporations are
interested so certainly when I was a PhD
student and when I was a young postdoc
it was a fairly niche area so you could
just kind of like fever away in your
little little kind of corner doing
things that you thought were
intellectually interesting and and being
reasonably secure that you won't get me
bothered by anybody but not like it's
not like that anymore
no into what what exactly was the
subject matter at the time what were you
working on at the time when I said my
thesis yeah
well I worked on how you could use this
is a tricky question I know you're this
is a you're asking me to go back let me
think what is it like 30-something years
yeah very something years yeah 30 years
I finished 30 years ago I finished my
thesis okay so what did it look at so I
was interested in logic programming and
Prolog type languages and I was
interested in how you could speed up
answering queries in in Prolog like
languages by keeping a kind of record of
thread of relationships between facts
and theorems that you've already
established so so instead of having to
redo all the computations from scratch
it kind of kept a little collection of
the relationships between properties
that you'd already worked out and so you
didn't have to redo the same
computations over again so that was the
main contribution of the thesis I'm
amazed or anything is not very
impressive I did mainly sis like five
years ago and I barely
and so did you pursue that further Adam
Mary oh no I didn't I I kind of from
well one other thing that I discussed in
my in my thesis that was I had a whole
chapter on the frame problem so the
frame problem is there are different
ways of characterizing it but the frame
problem in its knowledge is guys is all
about how how a thinking mechanism or
thinking creature or thinking machine if
you like can work out what's relevant
and what's not relevant to to its
ongoing cognitive processes and and and
how it isn't overwhelmed by having to
rule out just trivial things that aren't
irrelevant and so that comes up in a
particular guys when you're using logic
and when you're using logic to think
about actions and their effects and
their you want to make sure that you
don't have to spend a lot of time
thinking about the non effective action
so for example if I if I move around a
bit of the equipment like your
microphone here then the color of the
walls doesn't change and and you don't
have to explicitly kind of think about
all those kinds of trivial things so
that's one aspect of the frame problem
but then more generally it's all about
sort of circumscribing what is relevant
to your current situation and what you
need to think about and what isn't and
so how did that translate to what folks
are working on today well so it's
actually it's oh this thing the frame
problem has recurred throughout my
careers although there's being a lot of
variation in what I've done in life so I
worked for a long time in classical
artificial intelligence which is there
it's all about it was and still is all
about using logic like or sentence like
representations of the world and and you
have mechanisms for reasoning about
those sentences and rule-based a
rule-based approach and so that approach
of classical AI is fallen out of favor a
little bit and I sort of got a bit
disillusioned with it back in well a
long time ago
I'm soft so I kind of the turn of the
millennium I'd more or less abandoned
classical AI because I didn't think it
was moving it moving towards what we now
call a GI artificial general
intelligence the big vision of human
little AI and so I thought well I'm
going to study the brain instead I'm
because that's a example that we have of
an intelligent thinking thing it's the
perfect example so so I want to try and
understand the brain bit more so I
started working building computational
neuroscience style models of the brain
and thinking about the brain from a
larger kind of perspective and thinking
about consciousness and the architecture
of the brain and big questions and and
now I'm getting around to answering your
question but eventually but now I'm
interested in in machine learning
there's there's been this resurgence of
interest in machine learning so I've
kind of moved back to some of my
interests in in artificial intelligence
and I'm not thinking so much about the
brain or neuroscience or in that kind of
empirical work right now and I've gone
back to some of the old themes that I
was interested in in good old-fashioned
AI classical AI so that's sort of an
interesting trajectory actually the
frame problem interestingly is there has
been a recurring theme throughout all
that stuff and because it keeps on
coming up in one guy's or another so in
classical AI there was the question of
how can you write out a set of sentences
that represent the world well you don't
have to write up a load of sentences
that encompass all of trivial things
that are irrelevant and and somehow the
brain seems to solve that as well the
brain seems to manage to focus and
attends to only what's relevant to the
current situation and ignore all of the
rest and in contemporary machine
learning there's also this kind of issue
as well it is also a challenge of being
able to build systems especially if you
start to do to rehabilitate some of
these ideas from symbolic AI you want to
think about how you can build systems
that that focus on what's relevant in
the current situation and ignore things
that are not for example if you're in a
lot of this a lot of work here at deep
mind has been done with these Atari
computer games so if you think of a
retro computer game like space invaders
then then if you think about the the
little invader going across the screen
it doesn't really matter what color it
is it probably doesn't really matter
actually what shape it is either what
really matters is that it's kind of
dropping bombs and and you need to get
out of the way of these things so so so
so in a sense a really smart really
smart system would learn that it's not
the color that matters it's not the
shape that matters it's these little
shapes that fall out of the thing that
matter and so that's all that's all
about kind of working out what's
relevant and what's not relevant to the
to solving getting good score in the
game
sorry for the interruption everyone we
just got to see Garry Kasparov talk it's
pretty amazing yeah that was fantastic
wasn't it yeah Garry Kasparov in
conversation with Denis others yeah he
gave a great talk about the history of
his computer chess and you know his
famous match with deep blue so yeah we
just had to pop upstairs - huh and that
was part - yeah kind of one of those
once-in-a-lifetime things it also seems
like he got out at the exact right time
yeah maybe yes he did yeah yeah so
Dennis at the beginning of the interview
said that said that said that he thought
that he was perhaps the greatest chess
player of all time and so he was there
just at the right time to be knocked out
by a computer in a way yeah not knocked
off the top spot very cool yeah and he
also said that I'm maybe maybe
accurately that year any iPhone chess
player now is probably better then deep
breathing Libra live in 1997 yeah yeah
which is interesting yeah I also it was
interesting very he was saying that just
anybody in their living room now can sit
and watch two grandmasters playing a
playing a match and can use their
computer to see as soon as they make a
mistake and analyze the match you can
follow exactly what's going on yeah
whereas in the past it took you know
expert commentators sometimes days to
figure out what was going on when two
great players were playing yes that was
interesting what struck me was how he M
how he was kind of analyzing the current
play
and how they relied so heavily on the
computer or at least he thinks they rely
so heavily on the computer that they're
kind of like reshaping their mind right
yeah and that's certainly I think he's
going to be true would go and with with
alphago so so it's been interesting
watching the reactions of the of the you
know top go players yeah like Lisa doll
and KJ who are very positive in a way
about the impact of computers on the
game of go and they talk about how you
know how alphago and and programs like
it can help them to explore parts of
this universe of go that they would
never otherwise have been able to visit
and and it's you know it's really
interesting to hear them speak that way
yeah it seems like they're going to open
up just kind of new territories for new
kinds of games to actually be created
yeah indeed yeah well so we've already
seen that with art with alphago in the
in the match with Lisa doll so as you
probably know there was there was a
famous move in the second match against
Lisa don't move 37 where all the
commentators always sort of 9 Dan
masters were saying saying oh this is a
mistake what's what's alphago doing and
this is very strange and then they sort
of gradually came to realize that this
was a sort of revolutionary kind of
tactic to put new stone in that
particular rank in that particular time
in game and since then the top go
players have been exploring this this
kind of this kind of play about moving
into that sort of territory when the
conventional wisdom was that you
shouldn't hmm yeah I mean the
augmentation in general I find
fascinating across the board yeah and he
was hinting that as well yeah he was yes
so he was but was very positive about
the prospects of human-machine
partnerships and we're humans provide
maybe a creative element and machines
can be more analytical and so on well
what was that law that he mentioned I
forgot the name of it I wrote more of it
she's marvelous yeah yeah I named after
hands more of edge to the
roboticist who wrote some amazing books
including mind children so you like this
book mind children and and this this
phrase mind children lose to the
possibility though that we might create
these artifacts that are that I like
children of our mind and that they have
sort of lives of their own and they are
the children of our minds you know it's
a challenging idea this is an old book
coming go from from the late 80s okay
do you buy it I may be in the distant
future okay well then maybe we oughta we
had a segue back into what we were
talking about which is kind of related
to your book your two books ago
embodiment me in her life yeah yeah
which which came out in 2010 okay
because that was that was kind of an
integral question to the movie ex
machina right yeah as you you didn't
necessarily have to have a person like
AI and more importantly you didn't have
to have an AI that sort of looked like a
person that sort of looked like an
attractive female that also looks like a
robot right they tee it up in the
beginning
Nathan teased it up in the beginning
yeah yeah no I mean obviously sir to a
certain extent those are things that
make for good film trans generate their
artistic choices and cinematographic
choices and and I mean in the film her
we actually have a course of course a
disembodied AI and so it's possible to
make a film out of disembodied
artificial intelligence as well but but
obviously a lot of the plot and what
drives the plot forward in Ex Mac in
areas to do with a vers embodiment hmm
and the fact that the Caleb is attracted
to her and and sympathizes and
empathizes with her and but there's also
kind of a philosophical side to it too
which is certainly certainly I think
that it will no doubt when it comes to
human intelligence and human
consciousness our physical embodiment is
a huge part of that it's in its it's
where our intelligence originates from
because what we what our brains are
really here to do is to help us to
navigate and manipulate
complex world of objects in 3d space and
and and that is so our body Mint is an
essential fact here we have got we've
got these hands that we that we use to
manipulate objects and we've got legs
that enable us to move around in
[Music]
complicated spaces and so that's in a
sense is what our brains originally for
the biological brain is - is there to
make for smarter movement and all of the
rest of intelligence is a flowering out
of that in a way and so did you buy the
the gel that he showed Caleb in the
beginning oh yeah they said so so that
it's interesting because the way the
film is is constructed is that so Alex
garland you know the writer and director
so he sometimes says that the film is
set ten minutes into the future it's
just you know it's like a really
mentally like really a lot like our
world
yeah just very slightly into the future
yeah and so when you see the you know
Nathan's lair is a retreat in the in the
wilderness
it's there's nothing particularly
science fiction about that it's desire
narration of course it is in fact a real
Hotel in or wheel you can actually get
the stage relate in this place right in
Norway and so it so it so it you know it
doesn't have a particularly futuristic
feel and almost everything you see is
not very futuristic it's not like Star
Wars but then there are a few things a
few carefully chosen things that look
very futuristic and there
Ava's body so the way you can see you
know the sort of the insides of her
torso and and her head and then when he
shows the brain which is made of this is
gel and so I think that was a good
choice because we don't at the moment
know how to make things that are like
Ava that have that kind of level of
artificial intelligence so that's the
point at which you have to go sci-fi
really well I mean those like a lifelike
melding elements have you watched the
new show at the HBO show the West world
do you know I haven't no I mean I I yeah
I really am
is on my to watch list because but I've
heard a lot of a lot about it yeah
because they'd be directly original Yul
Brynner but I haven't watched the series
concierge yeah yeah they definitely take
cues I mean I guess it's it's probably
like in the sci-fi Canon that you have
this basement lair where you create the
robots and then they become lifelike
through this whole process even if you
just watch kind of a the opening title
credits it's exactly that it's like the
very the 3d printed sinews of the
muscles it looks exactly like Nathan's
lair and so what I was wondering is uh
as you were consulting on the show how
much of that were they asking you about
and were they saying like is this like
remotely 10 minutes in the future or is
this 50 years yeah well it wasn't really
like that okay I mean I'll tell you this
sort of whole story of how the yeah how
the kind of collaboration came about
without help
so so I got this email from Alex Garland
you know unsolicited email out of the
blue it's the kind of unsolicited email
you really want to get yeah from you
know famous writer director who wants
you to work on a science fiction film
and and he he basically said I I read to
your book embodiment in me and you know
life and it helped me to kind of
crystallized some of the ideas about
this around this script that I'm writing
for a film about AI and consciousness
and dude you want to get together and
have a chat about it so I didn't have to
think very hard about that and so so we
got together and had lunch and and he
sent me the script and so I'd read
through the script by the time I got to
see him and and he really he certainly
wanted to know whether it sort of felt
right from the standpoint of somebody
working in the field and an app so it
really did there was there was nothing I
mean it was as a script it was a great
page-turner actually a good it's
interesting being in that position
because now ex machina and the image of
a ver has become kind of iconic and and
you see it everywhere
and but but of course when I read the
script all of that imagery didn't exist
so I was reading it yeah I had to kind
of conjure it up in my own
hidden so I thought he didn't give you
any kind of preview of what he was
thinking in it so the note because
nothing had been nobody been cast then
at that point and I think actually when
we met up it's going with my memory
serves me right he did have a few he did
have some images of some mock-ups
Loretta from artists of what Ava might
look like yeah but I hadn't seen it when
I read the script so for me it was just
kinda script and and the characters
really left off the page the courage of
Nathan in particular was was really very
vivid and and you know you only didn't
like this guy in just reading the script
anyway so so then Alex really wanted to
is sorry so I sort of grabbed the title
of scientific advisor I'm not sure if I
ever really was officially you know
scientific about that but but Alex
really wanted to meet up and talk about
these ideas you want to talk about
consciousness and about AI and so we met
up several times during the course of
the filming and I was very little that I
contributed to the film at that point in
the sense perhaps I had already done my
main bit by writing library method and I
mean there are a few little phrases that
I that I corrected tiny tiny things but
otherwise I just I just thought you know
great yeah I'm really really very good
and there's some there are some lines in
the film that I just thought was so
spot-on anything you remember input like
what line project yeah well I mean so so
a favorite one is where where caleb was
so initially caleb is told that he's
there to be the human component in a
cheering test and of course it isn't the
Turing test but you know then he in
Caleb says that pretty quickly says well
look you know in the real cheering test
that the the judge doesn't see whether
it's a human or or machine and and so on
but of course I can see that you know
Ava's Aden and Nathan says oh yeah we'll
we're way past that the whole point here
is to show you that she's a robot and
see if you still feel she has
consciousness and I thought that was so
spot-on I thought that was an excellent
really an excellent point making a very
for the Safa cool pointing you know in
this one little line in the middle of a
psychological thriller with me pretty
pretty cool so I call that the garland
test ahem
so I found it very like that was really
stupid
I was wondering like which which text
influenced him most when he was writing
it and in particular like where you
found that your your work had seeds like
planted throughout the movie yeah where
do you think it was the most influential
well good question you need to ask him
mmm so so certainly the so my book is
very heavily influenced by Pitkin Stein
and and in a sense
Viktor Stein is all about when it comes
to these deep philosophical questions
it's very instances very down-to-earth
it's always saying well what we mean by
consciousness and tension allottee and
all these kind of big difficult
difficult words and and Viktor sly is
always taking a step back and saying
well what are the role of these words in
ordinary life and they're all of these
words in ordinary life is something like
consciousness is all to do with you know
the actual behavior of the people we see
in front of us and so you know in a
sense I judge others well I don't
actually go around judging others as
conscious that's a point that you make
as well it's just I just naturally treat
them as conscious and so why do I
naturally treat them as conscious
because their behavior is such that
that's that they're just like fellow
creatures and I just do that and that's
just what you do when you encounter a
fellow creature you know think carefully
about it and so this is an important bit
continuing point that I bring out in the
in the book very much and in a sense
that's very much what happens to Caleb
so Kayla doesn't you know isn't sort of
sitting making notes saying therefore
she is conscious
yeah but rather through interacting with
her he just gradually comes to feel that
she is conscious just and to start
treating her as conscious and so that's
a very something very victims Tinian
about that and then I think probably
that comes from I'd like to think I come
here from my book to expect well I'd
never um I get it seems very cinematic
that it would be like over the course of
a week the Turing test but I had never
seen a Turing test frame that
yeah I mean I guess it's not you know
it's a garland test but it did you did
you coach him in any way of like the the
natural steps that someone would take as
if the test to elevate no not at all no
this is all Alex Collins stuff I had I
had no input on that side it's also the
script was already and the plot was all
whole script was already you know 95
percent you know done you know when when
I first saw it ok so there are a few
differences in the final film from what
you see in the in the script that I saw
and indeed in the in the publish so that
was actually that was a question from
Twitter this is kind of a seemingly a
pseudonym on Twitter
someone trench shovel they asked were
there any parts of the script that were
changed or left out because they weren't
technically feasible or realistic ah
well well so there was a bit that was in
the script that was that was left out in
the final filming which i think is very
significant okay and so it's a right so
spoilers ahead ferret for the few people
I assume if you're listening to this
Selina so um so right at the end of the
film where Ava is climbing into the
helicopter and you escape from the
compound then she's got to kind of fly
off and she and we see her have a few
words for the helicopter pilot and you
know I wonder what she says actually you
know that's interesting that just fly me
away from here anyway and then off off
the the often helicopter goes now in the
written script there's that there's an
instruction there which says something
along the lines or we see you know we
see waveforms and we see the facial
recognition vectors fluttering across
the screen and we see this that and the
other and any yeah in it's utterly alien
this is how a first sees the world
mm art early alien and and now in the
end over so the very first version of
the film that I saw was long before all
that was before the VFX had been
properly done and everything so it was a
first
crude cut and they had they put sort of
the scene and they started they put a
little bit this kind of visual effects
in and then I think they decided this
didn't really work terribly well to do
that at that point now so they kind of
cut it out so in the version that we see
you don't actually see that that you
just see her speaking to the helicopter
quite and she climbs into the helicopter
but it's very it's a very significant
direction because you know we're left
now I think one of the great strengths
of the film is that it leaves so many
unanswered questions you don't really
need your life thinking is she really
conscious you know yeah is does she
really is she really capable of
suffering is issue just a kind of
machine that's gone horribly wrong or
Ischia a person who's who's
understandably had to had to do commit
this act of violence in order to save
herself you know which of these is it
and you never really quite know and
although I think people are leaning more
towards the kind of oh she's conscious
in a straightforward kind of way then
that's there but but that that version
of the ending yeah just points to the
fact that there's a real ambiguity there
because if that have been shown you
might be leaning more the other way you
might be thinking gosh you know this
this is a very alien creature indeed and
and she still might be really genuinely
conscious and generally capable of
suffering but it would it would really
throw open the kind of question now you
know how alien is she in to me that that
would also so just so I understand it
was it was a VFX over the actual image
right well I mean it doesn't in the
script it doesn't specify exactly how it
to be how it will be done so it just
says something like we see facial
recognition effectors fluttering and
wheeze and I can't remember the exact
word but it directly I think it was you
know the obviously the idea was to give
an impression of what things look like
and sounded like for Ava in some sense
which of course is free in a sense is
impossible to convey but you just have
to would would I think that's why
they've they thought how do we how would
we do this and well I didn't know if
they were also trying to avoid some kind
of I guess it's not really like a fourth
wall but it's also trying to um
trying to avoid the situation where they
the author or the auteur of the Alex
right of the movie is saying like we're
in a simulation like this is what you're
seeing as you are the mind of some an
artificial intelligence yes well I think
it was meant to be shown from her point
of view so for so right so that wouldn't
have been an interpretation of it if
they got it right I would imagine so
maybe but I don't know why exactly they
designed not to put it in but but it's
just the fact that direction is there in
this script and by the way that's in the
published script so I'm not naturally
I'm not giving anything away but there
is the published version of the script
has this little direction in it yeah I
rewatched it yeah i rewatch it last
night and I remembered the ending is
like it is so vague yeah okay what
happens and yeah I do I do remember
because I quite like that ambiguity yeah
you know they where you just you don't
really know really you know issue
conscious at all is she conscious just
like we are issue consciousness um kind
of weird alien way you never really know
and it's a this is a deep philosophical
question and there's also there's a
moment where right at the end where
she's coming down the stairs having
escaped basically she's going down the
stairs at the top floor of of Nathan's
compound and she smiles she does that
she goes up the stairs kind of looks
back in surveys yes yeah and she smiled
and and I remember saying to I said I
don't I don't think you should have that
after I've seen the first version I said
honey you should have that smile there
because it's it's to humor you know and
and and and you know and he was you know
rethought it was important to have to
smile there because because I think he
would he would say yeah so I think he I
think Alex would someone upwards and
yeah also I apologize to Alex if he's
listening to him I think he would he
would say that people of course can have
their own interpretations and that's of
course that's you know but he would
probably lean towards the interpretation
that she is conscious in the way that we
are and the evidence for that is well
why would anybody smile to themselves
privately if they weren't conscious and
just like we are
hmm and what else in those conversations
you know you're watching edits of the
movie what else did you guys work
through
well so there's the Easter Egg yeah sure
a good one yes which I'm sorry the
Easter Egg yeah so so the first time I
saw any you know any kind of clip of ex
machina as Alex sent me an email and and
said Lord you want to come in and see it
see a bit about Maki now as you know
because it's in the can as these film
people say though the no cans anymore
for the film to go in but so come and
see her kind of like in and come to the
cutting room so so I went along and and
he showed me some some scenes and at one
point he kind of stopped the stop
machine and um and he said it and this
is the moment where caleb is
reprogramming the security system in
order to release all the locks to try
and get out and and so alex froze the
frame there are right now you see these
computer screens where caleb is typing
into these computer screens and he said
you see this window here now this window
is all full of kind of some junk code at
the moment yeah and it says you can be
sure there are going to be there going
to be some geeky types out there who the
moment this thing comes out on a DVD
they're going to freeze that frame and
again say what does this do this is yeah
so let's give them an easter egg let's
give him the let's give them you know a
little cut right yeah so he said so he
said that basically you said that window
is yours put something in there and some
kind of hidden message and he said maybe
make it an allusion to your book mm-hmm
so I went so I thought this is very cool
and it isn't the best product placement
ever ever you know I probably sold one
other copy thanks so I went home that
very evening and I've made the mistake
that evening of buying a bottle of sake
and I and I was drinking this sarcasm I
go do for this I got got down coding
some coding something up in Python I'm
having a good laugh at what I was going
to do so I thought okay it got to be
vaguely kind of to do with security so
an encryption so don't have something
that kind of has some Prime's in it so I
wrote this little piece of this
of Eratosthenes a classic way of
computing primes and I wrote this so
instead of kind of getting off Wikipedia
or something i sat there encouraged it
myself but after fall after fall glasses
ass RK and I was coding this thing up
and and then basically computes some big
array of prime numbers and then there's
this thing that indexes into the prime
numbers and then add some random looking
other numbers to the numbers that is and
then those are ASCII characters and then
it prints out the cup what those ASCII
characters actually look like okay so
when you look at this stock code on the
screen it's just gobbledy good but
something to do with prime numbers if
you run it it prints out ISBN equals and
the ISBN of my book and bottom is only
in our life anyway so that was very
close very very very pleased with this
can I handed it over to them and they
put it in their inner limiting but but I
have to say Alex was wrong it wasn't
when the DVD came out that that oh no it
only had to be on BitTorrent for 24
hours long before the DVD came out
before there was there was pages about
this thing on the internet so there was
a whole reddit thread and there's a
github repository with my piece of code
and there's a reddit thread includes a
whole lot of criticism about my coding
style it's not Pepe compliant and I
really funny and it's true
is there any to but but why I really
regret was that the loop I put the wrong
terminating condition are no instead I
you know you can terminate the the sieve
of eratosthenes after N squared you
don't have to go all the way to n over 2
but for some reason I wasn't paying
attention for glasses of sake and I put
you know and it terminates after n over
2 times inefficient yeah well maybe
that's a bug in her code you know are
with maybe it's not a bug it's just our
own that can only give me some day you
know it's not actually a buck it does
meet the specification but fair enough
it's not efficient fair enough we should
ask some of these questions from Twitter
yeah I know they were very excited to
ask you questions so so we already asked
one so I'm Patrick out water let's get
to his question this is a ok so this is
we should have so Craig asked how much
closer we are to the sort of general
Hollywood style a I now
than we were in the 50s in the 50s so I
think what he's alluding to is the the
flying car you know a pastel version
like it's kind of the crazy futuristic
version of the AI in 50s yeah and then
the AI that they're portraying in movie
well I can tell you that we're precisely
60 years closer than 150 but I don't
think that's the kind of an circuit that
can treat them so well of course you
have to remember that in ex machina as
in all films the way that AI is
portrayed you know really a lot of it is
to do with making good film and
deafening good story and I mean in
particular people love stories where you
know where the AI is some kind of enemy
nemesis and so on actually garry
kasparov who we just heard speak made a
very interesting point to me about this
he said that there's that there's being
a currently pointed out and I think he's
right but there's been a kind of change
from very positive views in
science-fiction of utopian we're going
to use what we're going to kind of get
to the stars and to more dystopian views
of things where it's you know like the
terminator and so on but anyway certain
makes for a good story if you're if
you're AI is you know is bad and it also
makes a good story if you're a is and/or
deeds and if your eye is very human-like
and and whereas in reality you know AI
in two hours it's going to get more and
more sophisticated and closer and closer
to human level intelligence it's not
necessarily going to be human-like so
it's not necessarily going to be in
embodied in robotic form or if it is
embodied in robotic form it might not be
in humanoid form so in a sense of
self-driving cars a kind of perfect
robot yeah so I think that things you
know will be a bit different from the
way they seem the way the Hollywood has
portrayed them yeah of course if you go
back to the 50s and if we am it's very
interesting to look as retro
science-fiction I love retro
science-fiction it look at something
like The Forbidden Planet and then
Robbie of course in the Forbidden Planet
is this metal hunk thing you know which
is completely in Pratt
and you think how would it get around at
all and how would it do anything with
these kind of claw arms that exist and
hands that it's got so clearly we've
changed a lot in our view of what we
think we can the kinds of bodies we
think that we might be able to make in
there and I think it's also quite
difficult because there's there's not
really a clear benchmarking happening
right now that it because it's not
obvious it was if it was just like you
know energy and compute going into this
then the race would be I mean it
wouldn't be over but it would be very
obvious as who's winning and what's
going on yeah we're there it seems to be
that they're clear breakthrough
breakthroughs that have to happen yeah
that's certainly my my view so it so if
we're thinking about now the question of
when might we get to human-level AI yeah
artificial general intelligence then I
think we really don't know and as
certainly some people can you know you
can draw graphs that extrapolate
computing power and the sort of the how
fast the world's fastest supercomputers
are and and and you know we're pretty
close to what depending on how you
calculate it with pretty close to human
brain scale computing already in the
world's fastest supercomputers and we
will get there within the next couple of
years but that doesn't mean to say we
know how to build human level
intelligence that's an altogether
different thing and also there's
controversy about how you make that
calculation as well I mean do you know
how what do you count can counter neuron
how do you count the computational power
of one neuron and or one side apps and
and some people you know it may be that
some of the amounts of complexity in the
in the synapse is functionally
irrelevant it's just you know there's
chemically important and so on but it
might be functionally irrelevant to
Commission so we really have a lot of
open questions there but even if we
allow a kind of a conservative estimate
and we assume that that we're going to
have enough computing power that's
equivalent the computing power that's
equivalent to that of the human brain by
say 2022 or 2020 yeah we still would
need to understand exactly how to use
all of that computing power to realize
intelligence so I think there are
probably an unknown number of conceptual
breakthroughs between here and
yeah I mean specific AI absolutely
happening like this general yeah that
he's talking about yeah yeah exactly so
so yes so clearly there's lots of
specialist artificial intelligence where
we're creating really good things like
image recognition and image
understanding is and speech so speech
recognition is more or less being
cracked the act the adjust the process
of turning the way raw waveform into
text into and so that that's been
cracked but then again under real
understanding of the words that's a
whole other story and and while today's
personal assistants you know it can be
quite cool and they're going to get
better and better there's still a way of
displaying any genuine understanding of
the words that are being being used I
think that will happen you know in due
course but but we're not quite there yet
yeah I mean fortunately or unfortunately
because that also that underlies one of
the other questions that I that I did
won't ask so this is from Mecca Mecca
floss on Twitter so the question is
excellent movie but why is asthma as
MOFs law forgotten that would be the
absolute first thing they asked so just
for people who don't know what that is
there are three laws of robotics right
so I wrote these down so a robot may not
injure a human being or through inaction
allow a human being to come to harm it's
the first one - a robot must obey orders
given to it by human beings except where
such orders would conflict with the
first law and then the third law is a
robot must protect its own existence as
long as such protection does not
conflict with the first or second law
and so their point is basically like you
know why is the first of all broken in
ex machina yeah but of course asked the
most laws are themselves the product of
science fiction's yeah no they're not
real law men out there so so and so
Asimov wrote those laws down in order to
make for great science-fiction stories
and and all of the science fiction
stories Arsenal stories are you know
Center on the ambiguities and the
difficulties of interpreting those those
laws or realizing them in actual
machines and kind of often sort of moral
dilemmas as it were that the robot is
faced with in trying to uphold those
laws so so even if even if we did
suppose that we wanted to somehow put
something like those laws into a into I
mean to a relevant to robotics today but
if we do want to put them into into a
robot it will be immensely difficult so
I should take a step back and say why is
it irrelevant to robotics today so of
course let me qualify that of course
there are people who are who want to
build autonomous weapons and all kinds
of things like that and and and you
might you might say to yourself well I
would very much like it if somebody was
trying to pay attention to things a bit
like a Simoes laws and say well you know
you sure you shouldn't build a robot
that is capable of killing people but
that's that's a law that the designers
and all that would be a principle and if
we would have it that the designers and
engineers would be will be exercising
not one that the robot itself was
exercising so that's was the sense in
which is not relevant today because we
don't know how to today make an AI that
is capable of even comprehending those
laws so there so so that's kind of the
first point so so why doesn't it's a bit
okay but then when we're thinking about
the future of course is in ex machina so
why not well it would cause me again
make a very different story
if if if as the most laws were put into
Ava but but let's suppose that it was a
world where we were minded to put a
Simone's laws into Ava well maybe Ava
might reason that she is human we know
what is the what is the difference
between herself and a human and maybe
she she would reason that that that she
shouldn't allow herself to come to harm
and therefore she was justified in what
she was doing who knows I mean it's just
a story right yeah I think we have to
remember that it's just a story and and
and it's actually very important IIIi
think science fiction is really really
good
making us think about the issues but at
the same time we always have to remember
that it that it's just stories that
there's a difference between fantasy and
reality and I think it's also it is also
kind of covered in the movie when Nathan
and Caleb are debating I think he
Nathan's criticizing Caleb over going
with his like gut reaction as ego and
not in like if he were to think through
every logical possibility every action
he would never do anything right which
is kind of like directly against all
these laws but yeah Ava would never do
anything if she could harm someone
possibly down the road my you know
burning fossil fuel by being in the
helicopter well indeed yeah yeah yeah I
mean I guess we're all them well we all
have to confront those sorts of Dynamis
over time and I mean and indeed you know
moral philosophers have got plenty of
examples of these kinds of kinds of
dilemmas but make it obvious that
there's no simple single rule really you
know is enough by itself trolley
problems if you know that live well you
know the trolley is heading down the
track and there are points and and for
some unknown reason somebody is tied
across the tracks on one wonderful manic
very thematic and and on the other Fork
three people are tied across the track
yeah and the points are currently such
that the three people of the trolley is
going to go over the three people and
kill them and you are faced with the
possibility of changing the points so
that the trolley goes down the first
track and kills only one person so what
do you do and and you know philosophers
can can spend entire conferences
debating what the answer to this is and
thinking of variations and so on and and
that that little problem that little
thought experiment of Phillip Phillip
and foot's thought experiment there is a
is a distillation of you know much more
complex moral dilemmas that exist in the
real world absolutely so so before we go
I do want to talk about your thoughts on
and broader things here you know
obviously you work here we haven't been
bored yeah
things that then ex machina so obviously
you're here deep mind you're an imperial
as well twenty percent of the time yeah
can you talk a little bit about things
you're excited about for the future as
far as it relates to what you're working
on yeah well so I've so I've recently
got very interested in in deep
reinforcement learning so deep
reinforcement learning is is one of
those things that deep mind is made
famous really so when they published
this paper back in 2014 and the nature
version in 2015 about so they published
this paper about a system that could
learn to play these retro Atari games
completely from scratch so all of this
all the system C's is just the screen
just the pixels on the screen it's got
no idea what objects are present in the
game running just these raw pixels and
it sees the score and it has to learn by
trial and error how to get a good score
and they managed to produce this system
which is capable of learning a huge
number of these Atari games completely
from scratch and getting in some cases
superhuman level performance and other
cases human level performance and in
some cases it wasn't too good the games
and so they oh I think I'd opened up a
whole new field and to my mind out that
so that system is called DQ n to my mind
DQ n is in a sense of one of the very
first general intelligences because it
learns completely from scratch you can
throw a whole variety of problems at it
and it you know it doesn't always do
that well in many cases it does it does
pretty well yeah so so to answer your
question so I've got very interested in
this field of deep reinforcement
learning but when I sort of first gone
before I joined deepmind I first started
playing with their dqn system when they
made the source code public and I pretty
quickly realized that it's got quite a
lot of shortcomings as well as as
today's deeper enforcement learning
systems all have which is it is very
very slower learning for a start when
you watch it learning you think actually
this thing is really stupid
because because it gate might get too
super human performance eventually but
my goodness it takes a long time to do
an online base of errors yeah yeah or
even sit or even pond or something like
that so it takes an awful long time to
to do it whereas a human very quickly is
able to work out some general principles
what are the objects what are the sort
of rules then you work it out very
quickly and so it made me think about my
ancient past in classical artificial
intelligence symbolic AI and it made me
realize that there were various ideas
from symbolic AI that could be
rehabilitated and put into deep
reinforcement learning systems in a more
modern guise and so that's the kind of
thing that I'm most interested in right
now very cool yeah that was actually one
of uh one of my favorite questions from
the Kasparov talk today someone who's
working on go asked exactly that yeah
like how can humans compute so quickly
all like they compute what is not
relevant to the same and they can just
they execute the game I guess was chess
right in 50 moves rather than 100 moves
yeah yeah and it's very much that
framing yeah yeah that was Tori Tori he
was one of the people on the alphago the
team and and yeah that's a very deep
question I think he was asking that yeah
it's fascinating cool so if someone
wants to learn more about you or more
about the field in general what would
you what would you recommend if I want
to learn more about me I can't think why
they would want to invasion google my
name and for my website they want to
learn more about the field in general
well we're in a very fortunate position
of having an awful lot of material out
there on the Internet these days that
people can confined and all kinds of
lectures and TED Talks and TEDx talks
and so on and people want to know a bit
more technical detail there are some
excellent tutorial tutorials and about
deep learning and so on out there
that people can find there are lots of
massive MOOCs you know massive online
open courses so there's a huge amount of
material and out there do you have a
budding career and technical advising or
is there ex machina - ah so so people
are often ask me about ex machina -
which of course is none of my business
yeah but whenever I've heard Alex
garland asked about that he always says
he's got no no intention of producing an
ex machina to that it was a one-off
as for scientific advising yes other so
I have been involved in a few other kind
of projects I was a there was a theater
project I was involved in I enjoyed with
Nick Payne at the Donmar Warehouse here
my god so that was a service played by
Nick Payne was called elegy and it's
about an elderly couple who where one of
them has got a dementia like disease and
it's set also sort of ten minutes into
the future one of them has got a
dementia like disease but techniques
have been developed whereby these
diseases can be can be cured but the
cost that you have to pay is that you
lose a lot of your memories and and so
the play really centers on on the
difficult the difficulties for the
partner knowing that that her partner's
memories of their first meetings and so
on and their love is going to actually
sort of vanish so it's about that about
that and there's more of a neuroscience
kind of stuff and I've also been
involved with an artistic collective
called random international and random
international do some amazingly cool
stuff so I highly recommend a refugee
and to those famous for this thing
called brain room okay hmm and that MoMA
in New York yes that's right yeah
exactly yeah so it's to it but it was no
it wasn't ever in New York indeed yeah
so it so the idea there is that as you
since all their their art is using
technology in various kind of
interesting ways and often about how we
interact with technology you know to
make kind of art in our so in rain room
you the idea is it's a room with
sprinklers of the lasagne you walk
around in this room and it's raining
everywhere but there's some clever
technology that senses where you are and
you worked on that and know
all right company I should finish yes
yes so there's some clever technology
that senses where where you are and
turns off the sprinklers immediately
above your head so you walk around in
this room there accurately never getting
wet so so that's that's one of the
things that they also worked on on this
amazing sculpture called 15 points and
and this is based on point light
displays so a point light display is is
why these little displays where on the
screen you've just got safe 15 dots and
these 15 dots move around and you
suddenly you see that it's a person
because the 50 knots are like the elbow
joints and then the neck and the head
and the torso and the knees and so on
and you see these things moving around
and you instantly interpret it as motion
but you can even tell whether the person
is running or walking or digging or
often whether it's even whether it's a
man or a woman just by these 15 points
moving so they constructed this
beautiful sculpture which has been sort
of rods that have little lights on the
end rods and motors and so it's very
much a piece of mechanics and the
chemical robotic light mechanical thing
and and when you just see it stationary
it's just like this weird kind of
contraption but then it starts moving
and all the lights on the Ender and then
you suddenly you see does this person
appears walking towards you and I
thought that was a wonderful wonderful
example of how we could we see you know
we see someone there when the wind and
of course that for me that was very
interesting because it made me think
about when we do that with machines
really often we do maybe you know we
think that there's someone at home when
there isn't and them so that yes sir so
that a lot of their art is all about
that kind those kinds of questions
that's so cool I think that's a perfect
place to end it and what we'll link up
to all their work as well ok ok all
right thanks sorry yeah sure thank you
you